well they're so abundant they're easy to
find and that really got me started as a
youngster one of the things while
working on them instead of birds or
butterflies but then when I started
working as a teenager meaning taking a
serious interest in them with a plan for
later training and entry into entomology
in the money of the scientific study of
insects the career I discovered that the
ants were marvelous in so many ways from
their abundance their dominance the
environment what they're doing with the
environment they are so helpful to in
maintaining healthy environment they
have been for a hundred million years of
their existence they have the highest
social order of any creatures outside of
honeybees and human beings and I don't
understand why most people don't work on
that
you